foreign
we're gonna go out to
Cheyenne Wyoming and talk to Devin
what's up Devin
hey how you doing Dr John I'm good man
what's happening in your world
uh well we got five inches of snow I'm
leaving the gym right now great job
going to the gym in the snow that was a
dope flex and anybody listening to this
you're gonna sound Awesome by the way
like I'll just smell once I went to get
ripped what workout did you do today
uh we're doing back today
we're doing that ah are you a bro or
like you like got a jacked up truck and
you're just crushing it I really wish I
had a jacked up truck I have a small
little Nissan Frontier that I can't even
fit my two babies
good for you man you're my hero uh all
right so what's uh I don't know
understand this five inches of snow
business that would be an apocalypse
here in Nashville uh but what's up man
how can I help
so I submitted the question
um I currently work in a job that's
pretty affected by the political
environment
and wanted to know especially like with
all the uncertainty going on around you
know elections and the current political
environment how you navigate like
political anxiety
oh man that's a great question
um what kind of job do you have that's
contingent on politics I currently I
actually kind of have two I work for the
federal government both of them I'm a
current member of the Army National
Guard okay and I also work for the uh
Veterans Affairs Medical Center here
okay
um so what are what are your bigger
concerns are you worried about policies
are you worried about mandates what do
you what are you worried about
no uh mostly policies
um especially fiscal policy that could
affect you know my job oh okay so if
some if somebody came in and cut a bunch
of like uh defense spending or if
somebody came in and like uh if you work
in the medical establishment when they
mandated
um like in the original Desert Storm
those guys were going over and they got
like 500 shots and then the guys who
went over for operation
um Iraqi Freedom Got 5 000 shots and
then like the the coveted vaccine
mandates like so I'm not a veteran I
spent a lot of my career with him but
I'm not one my understanding is part of
entering into that Community is
you sign away that conversation
does that make sense
yeah I mean that's true and so I guess
backing out of it like I don't give
politics a second of my life none zero
and so if you're in a job that is
contingent on I guess any job at any
time could be subject to there being
challenges in the marketplace challenges
in your boss decides hey we don't want
to I think Amazon just decided hey we're
not going to do Alexa anymore instead of
laying off thousands of people like that
just happens
and that's why having
a building a non-anxious life having an
emergency fund not onlybody any money
choosing to drive a Nissan Frontier
instead of being a goofball and taking a
hundred thousand dollar truck loan out
right
um it sounds like you're doing the
things that allow you to if they came in
and cut a bunch of defense spending and
you suddenly found yourself laid off in
the federal government and from the
Veterans Administration which I highly
doubt
um then you're gonna be super qualified
to go figure out something else
is that fear oh yeah that's true what's
bigger is there something underneath
this what is it
um as a lot of it stems from you know we
man we have a hard
to baby steps we've backtracked into
baby step two we've backtracking to baby
step one got our way back to baby step
three okay and now we're
back in baby step two for people
listening um I work at Ramsey Solutions
and we have a program for teach people
how to get out of debt and help millions
and millions of people get out of debt
and take control get just get freedom in
their life
um and so uh when Devon's here's talking
about baby steps one and two and three
that's just a series of steps that
people follow to get themselves out of
debt forever
um
the debit card is not going to magically
save you why do you keep why do you keep
borrowing money let me ask you that way
we the only reason we actually went back
in the debt now was because of the right
now like five inches of snow my wife is
a stay-at-home mom and she didn't have a
car that could get through it to get our
son to school
and so that was the only reason I was
like you know what you need a car and we
went back in the debt and stresses me
out yeah sure it should yeah luckily we
got it in June it'll be paid off like
right at the beginning of the year but
okay so be done with it be done with it
yeah and then put yourself in your
family in a position that that doesn't
ever happen again
yeah that's my goal we can't cancel all
our credit cards close the accounts good
good for you hold it next time we get a
car it's going to be because we saved up
our money good for you we traded this in
and we're going to do it in cash yeah
it's good for you man good for you so
here's what I've found in my life when I
start getting anxious about things
one of the things our bodies do is it
starts looking for threats and are
things that identifies threats
one of the ways we do we that manifest
in our current world because we don't
have bears chasing us anymore is it
turns into we turn uh the world into us
as in them's we try to find somebody to
blame for our internal state
and what I would suggest is build a life
the best you can
so that not if but when your division
gets laid off when some knucklehead
politician makes some sweeping change
just so they can get some more votes
when your boss
gets caught you know with uh cocaine and
gets fired and then everybody go when
all that happens it's annoying it's not
catastrophic does that make sense
yeah
um and so that I mean
I just don't give politicians the access
into my life like that
yes I pay a ton of taxes okay
like I no amount of worrying is going to
make my tax bill lower
no amount of me like banging on things
and hitting things and getting mad is
gonna solve that right
true so I I just tend to go to things I
can control and then move on
um I don't know they can't make your
wife like you more they can't pay off
your house they clearly can't forgive
your student loans even though they're
trying to like they just can't I mean
I'm just not gonna give that to them
so let me ask you this why have you
given it to him
oh man dude break the cycle
break the cycle put Andy Griffith on the
TV
funny enough that's actually what we
play on our TV at the VA yeah you play
Andy Griffith that'll cheer everybody up
that's a good upstanding guy
um
break that cycle man
let your kids believe that their
neighborhood and their community and
their local church and their integrity
and hard work and discipline
daily practices that that has much more
to do has much more influence on their
future than some suit in some Capitol
Building somewhere
yeah that sounds like a good plan is
that fair
I I just
you sound like a young dad who's really
busting his butt and kicking butt and
working hard and
you found yourself with your pants down
again it snowed five inches not
literally your pants down but it snowed
five inches and all sudden you like went
and bought a car and I kind of I feel
sick doing this just on a borrowing
money on a depreciating asset at 14
interest or whatever they're charging
now
man
choose Freedom every time freedom from
the television telling you what to do
and how to live your life choose freedom
from I'm not going to owe anybody any
money because I don't want them speaking
into my life
I want to decide what I do tomorrow not
Toyota Motor Company I want to decide
what I do tomorrow not some toxic boss
that abuses me
I want to decide what me and my family
where we're going to live and what we're
going to do not some politician man I'm
just not going to give that person those
people access into my soul do I vote
yeah do I participate yes absolutely I
do and I go to Carnival and I throw my
one ping pong ball into the little bowl
hoping I get a goldfish and sometimes my
man or woman wins and sometimes they
don't then I'm done worrying about it
because no amount of Rage or anger
doesn't make gas prices any cheaper it
doesn't make
um us go to war or not go to war it just
doesn't
so I'm gonna get to know my neighbors
I'm gonna get to know my community I'm
gonna get invested in local politics if
that's that's for me not some national
politician but hey we need a road over
here hey we need a group of people to
help with the bridge over here
we need a new restaurant in our
community like whatever that looks like
for you
I'm not I'm just not giving them that
time and hopefully
um go to ramseysolutions.com if you
found yourself owning a whole whole
bunch of money
um if you find yourself in debt
because I tell you there's very few
things that will set you and your
marriage and your parenting
Freer than not own anybody anything and
there's a step-by-step program Financial
Peace University to get you out of debt
it's pretty it's extraordinary uh it
changed my family's trajectory man
changed our whole family tree
um check that out but beyond all
don't
don't get into Political stress they
just don't get that they don't get they
don't get rent free space in my head
anymore the space up here is expensive
now and if I know one thing uh they like
to spend other people's money not theirs
so they're not going to be renting my
headspace anytime soon